on va plonger dans l'horreur du 7
octobre avec vous Jérémy André et avec
les envoyés spéciaux du point en Israël
un numéro exceptionnel qui reconstitue
heure par heure le déroulé de cette
journée de massacre perpétré par le
ramasse un travail important un travail
nécessaire pour mesurer à quel point ce
pogrome au 21e siècle a été coordonné
regardez c'est dans l'invitation
d'amondingava on en parle juste
après
si on vous invite Jérémy André c'est
pour ce dossier majeur publié dans votre
journal Le Point 7 octobre 2023 un
pogrom du 21e siècle la bordure
occidentale du kibut de faraza ce kibut
Jérémy André vous avez été sur les lieux
des massacres on est dans une petite
maison qui sert visiement d'abri et où
on peut voir au sol des traces de sang
devant les maison des tirs donc voilà
des impacts de balles un peu partout
dans celui-ci c'est particulièrement
atroce je pense que là vous vous voyez
bien avec des coussins qui sont couverts
de sang cette semaine dans votre
hebdomadaire on retrouve un récit
presque minute par minute des attaques
du Hamas du 7
octobre à 6h30 la clôture de sécurité
réputée infranchissable est ouverte à 29
endroit les terroristes des brigades
alkassam la branche militaire du Hamas
rentrre sur le territoire
israélien le Dôme de fer le système
antimissile censé protéger Israël et
saturé des milliers de roquettes sont
tirées à 5 km de la bande de Gaza les
terroristes du Hamas foncent sur le
festival supernova plus de 3000 féards
tentent de
s'enfuir près de 300 tombe sous les
rafales de
kalashnikov les terroristes tuent ils
kidnappent aussi plus de 200 personnes
amené de forces à Gaza les terroristes
du Hamas prennent d'assaut plusieurs
kibuts ses communautés agricoles il
massacre des femmes des enfants des
vieillards au bout de quelques heures
d'une attente interminable l'armée
libère les kibuts et et découvre
l'horreur Jérémy André vous documentez
le plus grand massacre de juifs depuis
la Seconde Guerre mondiale et pourtant
vous le dites certains minimisent ou
relativisent alors pour convaincre
faut-il tout montrer tout
raconter réponse j'aisim André je pense
pas qu'il faille tout
montrer il faut raconter le maximum et
il faut bien choisir ses mots et les
détails qu'on raconte faut les vérifier
très précisément donc c'est le travail
qu'on a fait c'est un travail d'équipe
euh voilà avec une dizaine de
journalistes euh cinq sur place et euh
en essayant de collecter au maximum des
témoignages directs vérifier recroiser
pour vraiment en fait comprendre la
mécanique dans cette journée qui a mené
donc voilà plus de 1400 morts du côté
alors on va rembobiner le 7 octobre
c'est un vendredi jour de shabbat fête
religieuse en Israël et pourtant tout le
monde n'a pas baissé la garde on
l'apprend en vous lisant dans la nuit à
3h du matin le directeur général du
chinbet les services de renseignement
intérieur israélien remarquent une
agitation inhabituelle dans la bande de
Gaza et là alors une tentative il y
avait eu des d'envoyer mais non il y
avait eu des alertes pas seulement
celle-ci à la dernière minute mais en
fait plusieurs semaines auparavant entre
autres par exemple de jeunes femmes qui
observaient la frontière qui sont des
conscrit qui qu'on appelle les yeux de
Sal le long de la bordure de sécurité
donc plusieurs semaines avant et on ne
le sait pas encore il y aura une enquête
d'ailleurs l'armée l'a assuré à la
presse internationale il y aura une
enquête interne pour savoir les raisons
de ces
défaillances le jour même à 3h du matin
effectivement les renseignements
israéliens euh ont euh des doutes non
quelques quelques heures avant eu des
informations précises sur le Brand bas
de combat du côté donc du Hamas ils nous
ont envoyé des unités sur place mais
c'était beaucoup trop tard beaucoup trop
peu il aurait fallu renforcer la défense
de l'ensemble de cette frontière alors
on va voir sur la carte à la fois par le
nord et par le sud de la bande de Gaza
euh la barrière de sécurité il faut bien
montrer ces 6 m de haut 65 km de
longueur elle est franchi 29 points sont
sont franchis c'est énorme et il y a eu
des reconnaissances au petit matin point
de passage par des militants du Hamas
déguisés en agriculteur oui alors
c'était le cas encore une fois depuis
des semaines hein c'est ces yeux de
salle qui ont été d'ailleurs massacrés
on avait
interviewé
une une tente d'une de ces conscrites et
en fait sa mort a été annoncée ce
matin donc ses yeux de salle avaient
averti leur hiérarchie et en
vain ce matin là encore une fois elles
ont vu l'attaque arriver mais en fait
donc plusieurs personnes parmi ceux
qu'on a intervieé on parlait de li
iminau cette barrière de sécurité était
en réalité inadaptée à ce type d'
attaque et même donc certains militaires
disent aujourd'hui que la défense autour
de Gaza avait été négligé au profit euh
en fait de euh de s Jordanie et
l'occupation aussi la diversion par
cette pluie de de roquettes et puis ces
drones qui larguent des grenades pour
neutraliser les caméras et les et les
canons automatiques sur la barrière de
de sécurité il y a même des plongeurs
qui passent par la mer pour attaquer euh
certains certains kibibots et là avec
des engins les les commandos du Hamas
entrent et et quelles armes précisément
ont-ils alors finalement ils ont un
arsenal très abondant mais qui est
absolument pas surprenant donc un
arsenal de groupe armé donc de
kalashnikov parfois véuste de
mitrailleuse donc pk de fabrication
soviétique ou des imitations et donc de
de tuyau d'arrosage aussi j'ai vu
capable de fracturer les portes
blindéesexlosif effectivement
d'explosifs tout est préparé
minutieusement minutieusement préparé et
euh donc de lanceroquet donc euh ce qui
est spécifique c'est d'avoir tourné ces
armes non pas d'abord sur des bases
militaires euh voilà il y a quatre cinq
bases militaires qui ont été attaquées
mais en fait c'est surtout il y a une
vingtaine de localités civiles qui ont
été visées euh par ces armes et donc
voilà
d'armes lourdes sur des personnes
civiles désarmées et ce qui sidère aussi
ce sont ces caméras ces mini camérra les
fameuses GoPro que que ces terroristes
ont décidé d'emmener pour filmer leurs
atrocités alors je je je suis pas
certain que le but initial était de
filmer en fait la partie atrocité ou
c'est-à-dire que en fait depuis une
dizaine d'années les groupes armés les
groupes terroristes comme l'état
islamique filme de plus en plus embarque
euh des euh euh donc servic de médias de
cette groupe terroristes euh voilà qui
filment leurs actions et normalement en
fait ces vidéos auraient dû être monté
et diffusé je pense à la gloire donc du
Hamas et des autres groupes armés
palestiniens en en coupant en fait les
parties horribles ce qu'ils font
toujours ou peut-être en retenant
uniquement celle qui envoie un message
de choc d'effroid à l'égard de la
société israélienne là la différence
c'est que la plupart de ces terroristes
ont été tués au combat et donc l'armée
israélienne a récupéré énormément de ces
images et on a diffusé le contenu dont
des contenus qui sontement abominables
où il tuent des civils 6h29 la rêve
partie supernova qui bat son plein dans
le Négev c'est l'un des massacres les
plus insoutenables
281 morts et vous racontez la jeune met
benim qui comprend qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une fusillade du Hamas mais d'une
batue une batue dont les festivaliés
sont le gibier et qui va durer des
heures alors c'est cette jeune femme
c'est quel d'assez incroyable c'est la
capitaine de soirée donc elle est avec
ses amis c'est celle qui a on va dire le
moins consommé de produits parce qu'il
faut être très clair en fait c'est une
rêveptie les gens prennent de la MDMA ou
d'autres donc drogue hallucinogène et
elle elle est plutôt euh voilà nette et
en fait elle va emmener ses amis donc
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a utilisé comme
fil rouge elle a sauvé ses ses amis en
trouvant une cache
euh son témoignage ainsi que celui de la
dizaine de personnes qu'on a intervieé
sur ce festival sont très importants
parce que ils montrent un acharnement
sur les corps une une volonté de tuer
sur des gens qui sont complètement
désarmé et aussi et alors là c'est un
énorme problème je pense dans ce que
nous on a trouvé et ce qui émerge de
certaines images c'est la participation
de civils palestiniens des gens qui ne
sont pas en tenue de combat et qui se
sont joints parfois dans une deuxième
vague à ces massacres et ça ça pose
vraiment des
questions centrales sur qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé ce jour-là par par par
sympathie pour ce qui se passait par
alors il possible qu'un certain nombre
de ces gens soient des combattants qui
en fait n'ont pas eu le temps de se
préparer et sont joint euh donc au mass
il y a pas que ça hein parce qu'on va
parler aussi des héros des des Arabes
israéliens qui ont qui ont sauvé des Ju
je voudrais qu'on dise un mot sur omomer
landindler 27 ans rescapé du du festival
qui se souvient du sourire sur le visage
d'un terroriste poignardant une jeune
fille dans la poitrine les corps
perforés par les couteaux de cuisine des
morceaux de cerveaux éparpillés des
corps tellement carbonisés qu'il
ressemble à un squelette il vous dit
l'air sentait le faire tellement il y
avait de sang h alors je je pense que
son témoignage il est essentiel parce
que en fait c'est quelqu'un qui qui a
aussi traversé en fait tout tout ce
massacre qui allit dans plusieurs
endroits qui a vu en fait quelque chose
qui a peu été documenté c'est-à-dire le
le final vraiment barbare en fait de ce
massacre pour pour qu' 280 personnes qui
étaient tuées donc si on compare par
exemple à ce qui s'était passé au Kenya
en 2015 avec des étudiants il y avait eu
150 morts ce cétait passé à bomb donc en
2008 c'est on est probablement dans une
rien que sur ce festival sur une des
tueres de masse les plus importantes de
l'histoire récente avec et là on le voit
grâce au témoignag des survivants des
kibuts des communications permanentes et
ça c'est incroyable parce que les
groupes WhatsApp fonctionnent tout le
monde se prévient parfois on s'appelle
parfois même les terroristes ça c'est le
cas pour la rêve partie appelle les
parents des des otagees qui vont être
emmenés vers Gaza en leur disant tout
simplement vous ne reverrez jamais vos
fils ou vos filles bah c'est c'est un
massacre virtuel aussi qui se qui où
tout le monde communique enfin c'est un
maracre réel mais où tout le monde
communique en même temps ouais alors
c'est vraiment on est arrivé dans une
ère où il y a l'Internet est omniprésent
et et les applications sont
omniprésentes WhatsApp effectivement
dans de tous les côtés a eu un rôle
majeur on a en fait effectivement ces
groupes WhatsApp où les gens en live
comprennent des éléments sur la
situation donc on a par exemple ce cas
dont on parle c'est la famille de Keren
et avidor Schwarzman qui sont le kibot
faraza et en fait ils perdent le contact
vers 17h avec les grands-parents euh
donc qui vivent quelques maisons plus
loin euh et en fait sur le moment le
père donc avidor comprend en fait ce qui
se passe mais il le dit pas à sa femme
parce que c'est ce sont donc ses beaux
parents ce sont les parents de sa femme
et euh voilà en fait il y a quelque
chose de beaucoup plus instantané
aujourd'hui à cause ou grâce à ces
applications vous racontez aussi y
aiando l'ambulancier qu'on va voir à
l'écran qui font en larme quand il
évoque le corp d'une femme enceinte
éventrré lors de la conférence de presse
un éventré dont on a arraché le fétus on
le voit puis je voudrais que vous dis
vous disiez un mot aussi sur sur les
résistants sur les héros Rami vidane qui
sauvent des dizaines de jeunes et
Youssef zadney le Bédouin arabe
israélien qui a secouru les festivaliers
racontez-nous alors euh c'est c'est
quelque chose qui était peut-être passé
inaperçu dans le weekend d'horreur donc
du 7 octobre il y a eu des actes acte de
bravoure exceptionnel donc d'une part il
y a eu des kibboots qui ont réussi à
tenir en respect les assaillants donc on
on parle d'un de ces k boost donc
mfalsim voilà où une dizaine de
personnes armées ont réussi à tenir en
respect les les dizaines peut-être les
centaines de de personnes qui tentaient
d'investir le kibbots et puis cet homme
aussi oui et donc aussi donc en fait
c'est sauveteurs donc comme Youssef
comme Ramid davidan dont je parle aussi
dans l'article comme Léon bar qui a
sauvé met ben Rahim et qui est mort
pendant un sauvetage
après
donc et c'est ce que me disait met c'est
en fait on insiste sur le bilan mais en
fait s'il y avait pas eu cette
solidarité profonde dans la société
israélienne le bilan aurait été beaucoup
plus lourd merci beaucoup merci Jérémy
André et à toutes les équipes du point
les envoyés spéciaux en Israël et euh
les équipes de journalistes euh à Paris
je voudrais qu'on termine par cette
image le mémorial d'Aret que vous
reprenez euh sur deux pages euh à la fin
de ce très long euh papier euh c'est
aujourd'hui euh les
1128 noms de victimes on le voit ici
s'afficher officiellement identifié
c'est important aussi de tous les n
merci beaucoup Jérémy André c'est donc à
lire dans Le Point un porome au 21e
siècle sur 30 pages à ne à ne pas
manquer parce qu'il faut la regarder en
face cette réalité